I've known this guy a long time maybe
longer than some of you have been alive
um it's been 30 years and he's got a
heart that's made out of
gold okay and to jump off on his point
his question to me was so there you were
yeah flat iron partners partners with
Fred Wilson walked away from that what a
I am because I walked
away right well I mean I think you did
very well but you didn't do the next
cycle you you got off I got off I got
off the the the the roller the the
marryg go round yeah I mean and to be
clear so the story is I was
38 how many people are approaching
40 all
right you're going to be okay you're
going to get through it I promise you
I'm the old man I'm the other side of
the room you're going to be fine you're
going to be
fine I was 38 and then you know at that
point I was uh I often tell this story
by citing New York Magazine which called
Fred and I the princes of New
York um but now I'm going to change that
story I was the Jason calanis of my
day no you guys were big deal we were we
were hot definitely and it seemed like
everything that we touched turned to
gold and it was not far from the truth
you had a string
of close to a dozen Investments that
became unicorns and you did it out of
New York a place where people laughed at
that no nobody would ever be able to do
it from there yep and you guys did it
over and over and over again right and
the more successful I got the more
miserable I became there it
is because one of the things that can
happen is that you start to play for the
audience you start
to um get accolades and affirmation for
how well you're doing hey you're doing a
great job fantastic keep doing what
you're doing but I don't like to do what
but keep doing
it right and
um as my 30s ticked
on um I got to be around
38 and there's a seminal moment which
I'll which I'll speak to now and I I
detail of this more in my first book
reboot than in the new book
reunion in which I was you know a big
ass VC I had a portfolio company in San
Francisco and I had to get on a plane
and fly across the country and fire the
CEO and then get on a plane and fly all
the way back because that's what you
were expected to do and I got into the
house after this incredibly exhausting
day and um my then daughter Emma my my
daughter Emma who was then three years
old she's now 31 and engaged to be
married
yay
um was at the top of the
stairs and I looked up at
her and I spun around and and as I was
collapsing and going down hitting my
head on the bathroom door I heard her
say mommy mommy daddy
died and I said to myself what the am I
doing who have I
become Prince of New York the Jason
kelanis of my
era and
I am never G to stop giving in oh God
it's so brutal never it's so
brutal um because as we said last night
that's what you do when you're from
Brooklyn that's how you show love when
you're in Brooklyn well as a survival
Teck people don't understand uh because
what you do is you sit on the stoop
right and you just make fun of each
other that's right and then you make fun
of your moms and your brothers and your
dad you just and whoever cracks first
that's losing so you you just break
chops incess but incessantly incessantly
but it's a joke it's always good fun
that was the beginning of what took
about a year and a half of realization
that this was not the life that I was
meant to
live that it didn't matter how
successful I was and I was pretty
good this is not what I was born to
do you know I went through 911 which
kicked my ass
emotionally um Fred and I wound down
flat iron partners he went on with Brad
Burnham to start Union Square Adventures
I join JP Morgan if you ask him he will
tell you he threw me to the Wolves at JP
Morgan in order to get us out of the
contract we had to them I don't think he
did
that I just felt I could not do it
again and I I took this sort of interim
step of joining a big 20 $3 billion
asset under management private Equity
Firm I did four or five more Investments
and I was still
miserable
and from that
point I was working at JP Morgan and it
was a few months after 911 February 2nd
200 uh
2002 and I was down at at Ground Zero
which is what we called the pit the
place that was left
over when uh my old feelings of suicidal
ideation came
back and to be clear I had spent much of
my childhood in
depression so when this came back uh it
came back with a
vengeance and I made the best decision
of my life at that moment I decided not
to jump in front of that
train and anything good that I do in the
world today stems from that moment
deciding that this was not going to the
way it was going to end anyway don't
mean to bring you all too down so that's
how I left the Venture Capital business
I wandered in the desert for a few years
I had too many stupid board seats 27 at
one point at the same time and
eventually trained to become a
coach and I've been doing that now for
years our friends at Coran provide
Wealth Management Services centered
around you Coran's goals are to exceed
your expectations simplify your life and
help you establish a legacy that lasts
for Generations Coran has been helping
High Achievers just like you enjoy their
lives more fully preserve their wealth
and provide for the people causes and
communities they care about they're one
of the largest integrated fee only us
registered investment advisers and
corant has deeply experienced teams in
23 strategic locations each team has
extensive knowledge spending the full
spectrum of planning investing lending
and money management disciplines the
team at corant put the collective power
of their expertise into building you the
custom wealth investment and family
Office Solutions that can help you reach
your holistic financial goals no matter
how complex they may be real wealth
requires real solutions for more
information speak with an adviser today
at quant.com that's quant.com